When I graduated from the university...
...and for three years I tried to fill in the universities.
So I applied for jobs 30 times and got rejected.
I went for the police.
They said, "No, you're not good."
I went even to KFC.
When KFC came to China, came to my city,...
You applied?
...twenty-four people went for the job.
Twenty-three people were accepted.
I was the one guy.
And we went for the police.
Five people, four of them got accepted.
I was the only guy who did not receive it.
So to me, being turned down, rejected...
Oh by the way, I told you that I applied to Harvard ten times.
Rejected.
I know I'll be rejected, I just wanna say that.
They're sorry now.
Ten times you wrote them and said, "I'd like to come to Harvard."
Yeah.
And then I told myself, "Someday I should go teach there maybe."